[Musique]
alors avant de commenter ce discours
politique retour sur les grandes heures
de cette journée en afrique du sud la
sortie de prison avec un peu plus d'une
heure de retard cet après midi un homme
de 71 ans qui s'est avancé vers la foule
en tenant la main de son épouse philippe
pisteurs
nelson mandela tenant sa famille leur
donne ses premiers pas d'homme libre
premiers pas hésitants comme surpris de
la foule venue attendre
la dernière barrière franchie ses
parents sa prison du monde extérieur
15h15 à paris
l'instant historique qu'il ait pas 27
ans 6 mois et 6 jours et activités pour
cet homme de 71 ans
explose
bref ban cluj du symbole vivant de la
lutte anti-apartheid sans aucune
déclaration le couple mandela prend
aussitôt la route précédé d'un immense
cortège
direction l'hôtel de ville du cap à ce
que 100 km des dizaines de milliers de
personnes sont déjà massés là attendant
les premières paroles publiques de leurs
leaders depuis les premières heures de
la matinée cette foule immense attend
sous un soleil de plomb la violence va
malheureusement entaché cette journée
historique
une centaine de jeunes noirs s'en
prennent à la police j'ai bouteille
pillages de magasins riposte des forces
de l'ordre résultat un morts une
centaine de blessés
[Musique]